alors c'est
de tradition les collectivités dans la
vème république sont toujours flatté
toujours flatté souvent floues et
mais toujours flatté on vient vous dire
à quel point vous êtes exceptionnel on
vient vous dire à quel point vous devez
au coeur de toutes les dynamiques et
puis à la fin on envoie un préfet ou un
sous préfet pour vous expliquer ce que
vous devez faire et ça ça va être un des
enjeux majeurs me semble-t-il du
prochain quinquennat qui est évidemment
de repenser la décentralisation avec de
véritables compétences une autonomie qui
ne soit pas simplement parfois une forme
de décompte rang des concentrations sous
contrainte ou sous surveillance ce qui
m'a marqué
ces dernières années et ce qui je crois
vous interpelle toujours
c'est à quel point dans notre pays
nous avons perdu toute vision nationale
de l'aménagement du territoire
[Musique]